The answer is the second version is better and the reason for this is what would
happen if we defined a PandaBear class? And suppose out PandaBear can climb a
tree. So, we'll have a climb_tree attribute. With the first version, the
PandaBear will go hungry, even though it's able to climb a tree, because we
didn't know about PandaBears when we wrote this chase method, we only knew about
BlackBears and GrizzlyBears. With the second version, the PandaBear will be able
to climb the tree just like the BlackBear because its got a climb_tree method.
When we wrote the bear chase method, we didn't need to know about the PandaBear,
we just need to know what it means a climb a tree and what it means to knock
down a tree. I don't have a PandaBear but I do have a duck, quack, quack, and
this is what's known as duck typing, quack, quack.